the nfl's mock draft for the process on
thursday night happened yesterday
yesterday morning in football morning in
america peter king unveiled his mock
draft and peter some things in there
worthy of discussion and look we
understand that a lot of it is just
throwing a dart a lot of it is an
amalgamation of different rumors and
chatter and nobody really knows what
anyone's going to do especially this
year because without the pro day
workouts for all of the scouts to gather
in the gms and the coaches to compare
notes there isn't really a consensus
about anything other than joe burrow
being number one and chase young being
number two in the draft beyond that who
the hell knows what's gonna happen that
said and we talked about boston sports
and how they've been charmed to the to
the uh
chagrin of chris sims this this decade
this century
the thing that made me stop and pay
attention the possibility that if
tuatanga viloa trickles past number 10
here come the patriots rocketing up the
board to get tua
at number 13 i think is where you had
him in a flip-flop with the 49ers peter
what would you put a percentage chance
do you have a gut feel do you think
there's any realistic possibility of
something like that happening
i i doubt it i doubt it sincerely but
the only reason i did it is that in my
scenario
i have two of falling and you know what
tuatanga velo could be the third pick in
this draft he could be i don't know that
the dolphins are gonna pick justin
herbert
but
the essential the way i do mock drafts
is the way i've done them for years okay
i wait until close to the end so
starting about last thursday
i called
and and i would say there were 13 people
who i relied on
12 of whom are general managers and i
use one coach
and a couple of other people involved
there's two agents and and a couple of
other people in and around the league
so
my question to every one of them is
almost all the same okay because look
i'm not asking them so what's baltimore
doing at 27 or 28 wherever they are
we're talking about the top of the draft
and i had three or four really basic
questions this year
you know what's gonna happen to tua how
does your team see tua
uh you know did he pass your physical i
only had one team say that he didn't
pass that he would not that they had
taken them off their board because of
medical reasons okay and i heard that
there were several but i only know of
one
so i asked all these teams what's gonna
happen to tua
and
the most the biggest reaction i got is
basically they didn't think that chris
greer was gonna take the chance
uh and i i can't put it any more simply
than that uh that most people in the
league right now entering thursday night
the ones who i talk to right so i mean i
sh i clearly did not talk to everybody
every team in the league but most people
i talk to think that the dolphins are
gonna steer clear of tua
if that happens okay then you ask
yourself who's gonna take him
you know he's clearly one of the best
prospects in this draft uh and still is
one of the best prospects in this draft
you know even with his hip the way it is
but if he starts sinking mike
that is what i had to try to measure
who might pick him now carolina might
pick him
you know they've got the offense that
would be really good for tua with joe
brady however
if they pick him
how are you going to have teddy
bridgewater
you know in tuatangavaloa on this team
for at least the next two years i mean
if you cut teddy bridgewater next year
and hand the ball to tua it's a 20
million dollar cap charge
so you know are you set up to do that
i don't think so so then you go okay who
else could take them
oakland or las vegas at 12. now that is
a real legitimate possibility
but
that is one of the other questions i
asked everybody
what do you think of gruden and mayok
taken tua
and i didn't find much sentiment for
that at all
and so then you you keep going down and
i just started to wonder okay look at
all the teams
beneath oakland at 12. mike you just go
down those teams
and i don't see many or any teams right
now that would take a risk like that in
the first round of a draft
on tuatanga veloa except
for one of nick
saban's best friends in the world bill
belichick that's what it came down to
there's a lot of good logic there peter
i mean there really is i mean first off
with the two of conversation listen i i
know i might be different than most i
don't think he's a top 10 talent even
without the injury but with the injuries
but with the injuries i just look at it
and go there's no way you'd have to be
crazy i mean there's there's rumors out
there that he needs another ankle
surgery here you know that i hear from
people that i trust around the nfl that
he might need another clean up procedure
you know let alone being a small guy and
plays kind of a backyardish type of game
at points too
so i i mean i would be absolutely
floored jaw on the floor shot okay just
shocked if tua ended up being picked in
the top ten i would think for sure once
he hits number 10
business will be open for tua and to me
the big thing is yes you know i don't
want to i'm good for lack of a better
way to say it what owner's going to be
the sucker that's going to sit there and
go oh man oh man two is on the board we
need to it you're right i don't think
it's new england i don't think he's a
new england type of guy i mean belichick
traditionally likes bigger type pocket
passing quarterbacks two is not that to
me and everything i know up in new
england they like jared stidham so i
just don't know if that is but you bring
up a lot of good questions there yes the
vegas thing is real you know also i just
throw into this like you know the
jacksonville jaguars if they're sitting
there right now right pick 20 and if two
is sitting there in the mid teens is the
khan family gonna start going man i know
we like gardner minshew but this is
tuataga viola from alabama alabama's
right down the road from jacksonville
it's sec country that's one that jumps
out to me at least a little bit
logically
absolutely you know i think that is a
that is an excellent excellent point by
you chris and more than one team said
that
but the biggest question i have and i
thought you were gonna say at nine i
definitely don't think at nine i think
they're gonna go for the second corner
in the draft if he's available cj
henderson but sure i do think there's a
real a real two roadblocks for a
possible new england pick and why i
think they'd have to trade up if they
wanted them and that is vegas at 19
jacksonville at 20. both of those teams
in my opinion regardless of what they've
said or how they position themselves
would be real contenders for tua right
around there
well i'd be stunned if the jaguars took
two i hadn't really thought about it
before and this isn't a team that has
really gone out of its way in the past
to pander to the locals they had a shot
at tim tebow there were people in the
media who thought that the jaguars who
even reported the jaguars were going to
sign tim tebow and it never happened
local guy right you've got that local
connection to alabama the other thing
too is they i feel like they want to
give gardner mitchu a full and fair shot
to become the guy because the people
there love him so much that would be a
tough call if he's there at 20. and boy
if he's there at 20 think about that
think about how the world changes in a
year from the perspective of the draft
we all thought tool was number one you
throw in the hip injury you throw in joe
burrow and it very well could be that to
tour slides and slides and slides
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports